hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today is Thursday so that means
the Warriors then dev stream was today
so I decided to recap it for you all
like I do every week so let's get
started so the first thing on the list
is that this new weekly content is new
mythic outfits and obviously with those
mythic outfits come effects and they got
some pretty damn cool effects so I'll
play the video for you guys and we'll
reconvene afterwards so see you when
that's done
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so those were the outfits they're gonna
be costing 15,000 steal like normal
mythic outfits I'm really I really do
like these the the Viking one was super
flashy with all the bones and everything
and the samurai one makes you look more
like a weave than you already are the
nice one was pretty dope as well so I
really do like in these outfits gonna
have to grab that especially for
gladiator and Kenzi but next up before
we get into the other little bit of news
I just wanted to mention that I might
actually start streaming again I've been
busy with school for the past two to
three weeks and I haven't really had
time and the people that did come out
did really enjoy it so I'm gonna
hopefully try to stream tomorrow or on
Saturday or at around the same time this
video is gonna be going live so if I if
I do tend to stream though if I do
stream on those days look out for that
at around that time I'd love to see you
all there be the way continuing on there
was a few quick notes uh really quickly
though the overall population for the
tournament mode is now balanced instead
of what it used to be so glad
everything's working and seems to be in
order and they're still trying to get
pts on council so hopefully they can it
will benefit this game greatly but if
you're on PC unlike me you can go play
the pts right now I believe it's up for
the week or the weekend I think it's the
week it'll be up for the week and you're
playing the tribute mode so definitely
we'll go to that go to the pts write a
page and ask all the changes that are
bugs that you discover so that they can
fix it so the tribute mode becomes bug
free and as an a hassle next up they
should have written they had a lot of
Q&A like a really big Q&A session but
before I wanted to show you guys two
images I found on reddit so credit to
these two guys and their names are g'day
go and chaos art - I super apologist if
I butchered these names but thank you
all for sending in those photos on
reddit of shoutouts to them but these
are these photos just to be you'll be
seeing on screen the first one is in the
settings menu and this was all during
the pts today and it looks like we're
gonna be able to tune our guard stance
angles as well as the dead zone and
hopefully be able to remap our controls
so hopefully if everything goes smoothly
during the pts those will come to
console and PC as well and then next
photo is a screen
and under the outfit section next to the
reputation tab there's a new tab called
masks so this is probably gonna mean
that characters are gonna get own custom
acts besides gear maybe you can like you
know maybe color it or get a spray paint
or some type of stuff like that maybe in
a whole new mask in general so I'll be
really hopeful now I'm really happy to
see this obviously more content more
customizations always good and big
customization guy but we'll have to see
what these look like obviously in the
future these aren't gonna be coming out
anytime soon and then regarding
Highlander though I know he doesn't have
a mask he's the only character in the
game without a mask
so probably just beginning face paint
which kind of sucks but at least he's
included that's my take on it though let
me guys let me know what you guys think
about these screenshots anyway but to
sum up the QA really quickly
defensive meta changes will be in season
four and they are confirmed to be in
season four time snap has yet to be
fixed but they're working on a solution
Flickr is also being fixed and the
changes are being tested in the pts so
if that goes smoothly in the pts it'll
move to the full game gladiators dodge
tracking is finally being fixed next
patch if any of you are gladiator mane
such as myself you understand what I
mean and it's a pain in the ass so
they're gladly fixing this any of you
conquer players out there your bra's
being fixed next patch is well the
Centurion his little ho-ho kind of thing
that he spams so that's definitely being
fixed that's going back to what it used
to be the new characters gladiator and
Highlander we'll soon have rewards in
the tournament ranked mode there was one
of the problems I had is that why would
why would I play ranked mode if I didn't
have a character the head rewards I
already got the Kensei ornament so there
was really no point for me to playing
ranked but hopefully once they add that
I'll start playing it more regarding
inventory space for each character it's
very hard to increase because of its
performance reasons but they're looking
for more crowns to obviously get us more
than 60 spaces at a time for each of the
characters and finally putting
engravings on your weapons might soon be
a thing in for honor no exact date yet
but they said it might come in the next
season personally I think this is gonna
be cool if they have the engravings for
what they have for the helmets in the
armor maybe not so much maybe weapons
specific engravings would be nice but
still more content I'm always there for
more content
but either way
Subic stream is going to be a long one
with lots of patch notes so be on the
lookout for that a stream if you're
gonna be on that stream and if you can't
make the stream it's completely fine
I'll recap it for you here next Thursday
like I always do
so we're gonna be it's gonna be a lot of
patch notes so I'm really excited to see
what they're gonna bring to the table
for this one it said it's supposed to be
super long so left to see about that be
the way guys that's gonna be the end of
the video today I hope you all did enjoy
this recap if you guys did like the
video please hit the like button it
really does help me out as much as you
think it doesn't it really does
subscribe if you're new I always do
these stuff stream recaps I also do
other videos on the side before honor as
well so be on the lookout for those my
two newest videos we pop it up on screen
right now and with that guys I will see
you all later peace out